[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport ein schönen guten Abend
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
Einigung im Streit um verbrennermotoren
wenn sie ausschließlich efuels tanken
dürfen sie auch nach 2035 zugelassen
werden
Trinkwasser wird knapp eine UN-Konferenz
will mit einem 700 Punkteplan
gegensteuern
und Dienstbeginn an der Säbener Straße
Thomas Tuchel startet als neuer Trainer
des FC Bayern
das wochenlange Gitarre ist vorbei
EU-Kommission und Deutschland haben sich
geeinigt auch nach 2035 dürfen EU-weit
Autos mit verbrennermotoren neu
zugelassen werden wenn sie
ausschließlich klimaneutralen Kraftstoff
tanken
Greenpeace spricht von einem faulen
Kompromiss der die dringend nötige
Ausrichtung der Automobilbranche auf
effiziente Elektromobilität verringere
die FDP feiert die technologieoffenheit
Christiane hübscher hat Details für
Volker Wissing ist es ein guter Tag sein
langer Streit mit Brüssel sei zugunsten
der FDP beigelegt verkündet der
Bundesverkehrsminister jetzt hat sich
die EU-Kommission mit uns nach langen
Verhandlungen darauf verständigt dass
wir nach 2035 in Europa Fahrzeuge mit
Verbrennungsmotor und synthetischen
Kraftstoffen zulassen und das ist ein
gutes Signal für die EU bestätigt
kommissionsvize Timmermanns wir haben
eine Einigung mit Deutschland über die
künftige Nutzung von ifius in Autos
diese mit Ökostrom erzeugten
synthetischen Kraftstoffe sind zwar
klimaneutral aber längst nicht marktreif
zu teuer und zu ihnen effizient sagen
Experten die Futures werden ein Nischen
Thema bleiben auch nach 20:35 wir werden
Massenmarkt sehen und wir brauchen die
für andere Transportsektoren Schifffahrt
schwerer Lkw Transport der Bundeskanzler
begrüßt zwar heute bei einem
Bürgergespräch in Potsdam die Einigung
bleibt aber ebenfalls realistisch
können eine Möglichkeit sein wie viele
davon Gebrauch machen und ob das
überhaupt
relevant wird das kann niemand sagen die
Grünen die ifus auch nur für ein
Randthema halten wirken erleichtert dass
der Streit vorbei ist es ist sehr gut
dass es jetzt eine Einigung gibt und
aber auch außerdem die Bedenken meines
Kollegen Volker Wissing und der FDP
ausgeräumt werden konnten sodass wir es
mit der Arbeit weitermachen können für
die efuse hat der Deutschland auf Wunsch
der FDP eine Abstimmung über das
Verbrenner aus in Europa blockiert
bisschen glaubt nun die Ausnahme sei
rechtssicher Zweifel kommen aus dem
EU-Parlament wenn er Wissing sagt dass
verbrennerverbot ist vom Tisch dann ist
das falsch ich ähm rechne damit dass
dieser Delegierte Rechtsakt auf den Herr
Wissing so gedrängt hat vom Europäischen
Gerichtshof kassiert wird kommenden
Dienstag soll nun das Verbrenner aus
dass kein echtes Verbrenner aus mehr ist
von den 27 Mitgliedsstaaten
verabschiedet werden
also so ganz ist das noch nicht in
trockenen Tüchern Theol in Berlin was
hat die FDP von dieser Einigung und was
ist der Preis dafür
der Preis ist eine deutliche Verstimmung
bei vielen europäischen Partnern wobei
sich das eigentlich zum Teil ja auch
gegen die EU-Kommission richten müsste
denn die Forderung der FDP war dort
immer bekannt und steht ja sogar schon
im Koalitionsvertrag aber offensichtlich
hat keiner damit gerechnet dass die
Liberalen das so beinhart durchziehen
würden und das hat nach fünf verlorene
Landtagswahlen natürlich auch damit zu
tun dass die FDP das Auto als ein
politisches gewinnerthema identifiziert
hat mehr als zwei Drittel der Deutschen
lehnen ein Verbrenner aus ab und über
70% fürchten einen Schaden für den
autostandort Deutschland und das dürfte
sich auch morgen beim Streit im
Koalitionsausschuss zeigen da wird die
FDP für weiteren Autobahnausbau kämpfen
sehr zum verdros der Grünen die finden
sie hätten die Last der unbeliebten
klima-maßnahmen allein zu tragen
Stichwort Heizung und würden davon in
den Umfragen dann nach unten gezogen
also auch für die Ampel gilt zunehmend
politische Inhalte haben strategische
Preisschilder danke schön für diese
Einschätzung aus Berlin Theater
wie werden efues eigentlich hergestellt
und wie nachhaltig sind sie ein
Erklärvideo und weitere Antworten zu den
wichtigsten Fragen zum Thema finden Sie
in unserer ZDF heute App
russland will taktische Atomwaffen in
Belarus stationieren das gab Präsident
Putin vor einer halben Stunde im
Staatsfernsehen bekannt zehn Flugzeuge
stünden dort bereit die solche Waffen
tragen könnten
internationale Abkommen würden dadurch
nicht verletzt sagt Putin schließlich
hätten die USA ebenfalls Atomwaffen in
Europa stationiert
bis 2030 klimaneutral werden dieses Ziel
haben sich schon mehrere Städte gesetzt
in Berlin Stimmen morgen die Wähler und
WählerInnen darüber erfolgsentscheid ab
es geht darum ob der Senat per Gesetz
verpflichtet werden soll die CO2-Bilanz
der Stadt in nur sieben Jahren auf Null
zu senken heute wurde noch mal kräftig
für die Abstimmung geworben Roman
leskova
musikalische Unterstützung kurz vor der
Abstimmung die Initiatorin des
Volksentscheides werben am Brandenburger
Tor für Ihr Anliegen weitgehende
Klimaneutralität in Berlin nicht erst
2045 sondern schon in sieben Jahren ein
ambitionierter Plan geben sie zu aber
machbar die
recherchiert hat das ist möglich ist die
Energieversorgung komplett CO2 neutral
zu gestalten bis 20 30 zusammen in
Berlin neben dem Energie Sektor wären
weitere schnelle Schritte nötig der
Gebäudebestand braucht Solar auf den
Dächern und energetische Dämmung und
auch der Verkehrssektor müsste kurzer
Zeit umgebaut werden Wissenschaftler des
iöw haben das Szenario für Berlin
durchgerechnet selbst bei deutlich mehr
Tempo halten sie das Ziel 2030 für
unrealistisch
selbst wenn diese Hebel in Bewegung
gesetzt werden sind insbesondere der
Gebäudebereich und der Verkehrsbereich
diejenigen die mehr Zeit brauchen weil
energetische Gebäudesanierungen eben
sich erst sehr langsam entwickeln wird
und auch im Verkehrsbereich das Schaffen
von Angeboten und der Austausch von den
Fahrzeugen das wird länger dauern ein
machbares Ziel oder Illusion die
Meinungen zum Volksentscheid gehen in
Berlin auseinander ich bin dafür es ist
ganz wichtig einfach einen Schritt nach
vorne zu gehen auch wenn ich alles
erreicht wird weil das nicht nicht
durchführbar ist eine kurzen Zeit die
Initiatoren und ihre Unterstützer hoffen
auf ein positives Foto morgen der
Volksentscheid zu glauben sie könnte
Signalwirkung auch für andere deutsche
Städte haben
[Musik]
zum ersten Mal ist ein katholischer
deutscher Bischof wegen seiner Rolle im
Missbrauchskandal zurückgetreten der
Vatikan hat das gesucht des Osnabrücker
Bischofs Franz Josef Bode jetzt
angenommen ein Untersuchungsbericht
hatte wurde schwere Fehler vorgeworfen
er sei seiner Verantwortung nicht
gerecht worden sagte der 72-Jährige in
einer Stellungnahme
insbesondere im Umgang mit Fällen
sexualisierter Gewalt durch Kleriker
habe auch ich selbst lange Zeit eher die
Täter und die Institution als die
Betroffenen im Blick gehabt ich habe
Fälle falsch eingeschätzt häufig
zögerlich gehandelt und manchmal falsche
Entscheidungen getroffen
fragen wir unseren kirchenexperten
Jürgen Erbacher welche Bedeutung hat
dieser Rücktritt der Papst hat in der
Vergangenheit ja mehrfach
rücktrittsangebote abgelehnt etwa des
Hamburger Erzbischofs hese oder von
Kardinal Marx aus München das hat nicht
nur bei Betroffenen sexualisierte Gewalt
zu großem Unverständnis geführt daher
war es ein längst fälliger Schritt das
endlich auch auf oberster Ebene in
Deutschland Verantwortung übernommen
wird wenn es Fehlverhalten gab das
Beispiel Bischof Bode zeigt zugleich wie
schwer die Krise in der katholischen
Kirche in Deutschland ist er ist einer
der profiliertesten Reformer gewesen und
hatte großes Sympathien über viele Jahre
als er dann aber im September nicht
zurückgetreten ist nachdem eine Studie
im Fehlverhalten vorgeworfen hat hat er
massiv an Rückhalt verloren das zeigt
wie bei manch anderen Bischöfen in
Deutschland die wichtigste Währung hat
ihm gefehlt für sein Amt das Vertrauen
vielleicht hat man jetzt im Vatikan
Begriffen neben der Debatte über
Strukturen und Theologie ist es wichtig
dass es personelle Konsequenzen gibt um
wieder Vertrauen zu gewinnen
danke schön Jürgen Erbacher für diese
Information
un Generalsekretär gutärisch spricht von
einem Meilenstein auf der ersten
wasserkonferenz seit 50 Jahren haben die
Vereinten Nationen mit mehr als 6000
Vertretern von Regierungen NGOs und
Unternehmen in New York beraten Ergebnis
ist ein Aktionsplan mit mehr als 700
Punkten
darunter sind Maßnahmen zur
Renaturierung bessere Anbaumethoden und
die Unterstützung ärmerer Länder im
trinkwassermanagement allerdings ist das
Papier nicht verpflichtend Johannes Hano
sauberes Wasser wie hier in Chile am
Fuße der Anden Grundlage allen Lebens
auf unserem Planeten doch sauberes
Wasser ist zu einer knappen Ressource
geworden mehr als zwei Milliarden
Menschen haben kein gesicherten Zugang
weltweit sterben jedes Jahr allein 1000
Kinder unter fünf Jahren an den Folgen
verschmutzten Wassers so UNICEF und
Wasserknappheit ist längst kein Problem
das Armen südensmeer wir haben die
Nachrichten das in Italien und
Frankreich durch eine winterdöre sowohl
die Wasserversorgung als auch die
Versorgung der Atomkraftwerke in
Frankreich problematisch ist und die
Alpengletscher immer stärker schmelzen
so dass wir auch in Deutschland in
Europa uns für nachhaltiges Management
den Schutz unserer unseres höchsten
Gutes des Wassers stärker engagieren
müssen drei Tage haben hier in New York
die Vereinten Nationen gemeinsam mit
mehr als 6000 Vertretern von NGOs und
Unternehmen beraten herausgekommen sind
freiwillige Selbstverpflichtungen für
eine nachhaltige Wasserwirtschaft eine
un-wass beauftragter soll in Zukunft das
ganze koordinieren wenn die Welt das
Wasserproblem nicht schnell in den Griff
bekommt hat das katastrophale Volk
drohen Verteilungskämpfe Massenmigration
und wirtschaftliches Desaster da waren
sich ja alle einig mittlerweile hat man
erkannt dass man nur gemeinsam die
Probleme lösen kann die Konferenz hier
in New York kommt dafür aber nur der
Auftakt sein in zwei Jahren soll es eine
Folgekonferenz geben und die Zeit drängt
denn bis 2030 so die UNO wird der
weltweite Trinkwasserbedarf 40% über dem
Angebot liegen
der US-Präsident bekommt derzeit den
Unmut von Millionen von Jugendlichen zu
spüren auch aus Deutschland weil beiden
neue Ölbohrungen in Alaska genehmigt hat
protestiert wird längst nicht mehr nur
auf der Straße die Wut der jungen
klimaaktivisten entlädt sich vor allem
im Netz das sogenannte willow-projekt
soll im Norden von Alaska entstehen und
umfasst drei neue Ölfelder über das Für
und Wieder berichtet Claudia Bates
ein Refugium für Karibus und Eisbären
ist der Norden Alaskas aber unter der
Erde hier liegen auch 600 Millionen Fass
Öl konako Philips fördert hier seit
Jahrzehnten die beiden Regierung
fürchtete einen möglichen Rechtsstreit
über neue Bohrungen ohnehin zu verlieren
und gab grünes Licht der Präsident unter
Beschuss
er behauptet ihm sei die Klimakrise
wichtig er wolle umweltgerechtigkeit und
das Artensterben angehen aber dieses
Projekt wird alle drei Krisen
verschärfen
der CO2-Ausstoß des sogenannten
willow-projekts wird dem von ca 1,7
Millionen Autos pro Jahr entsprechen
Präsident beiden bricht mit der
Genehmigung ein zentrales
Wahlkampfversprechen
keine Bohrungen mehr auf öffentlichem
Land Punkt Punkt Punkt
doch beiden steht innenpolitisch unter
Druck die Abhängigkeit von fremdem Öl zu
reduzieren außerdem sollen die Einnahmen
die Wirtschaft in Alaska Stärken ein
Zusammenschluss dort heimischer
Ureinwohner befürwortet die Bohrungen
die Steuern aus diesem Projekt
finanzieren unsere Schulen Infrastruktur
Wohnungsbau deshalb bedeutet es unseren
Stammesmitgliedern
seit Monaten gibt es Proteste Petitionen
mit Millionen von Unterschriften
aufgebrachte junge Umweltschützer teilen
ihre Sorgen auf Social Media
Gruppen ziehen gegen das Förderprojekt
vor Gericht
Schwule Lesben bisexuelle transmenschen
weltweit leiden viele von ihnen noch
immer unter Diskriminierung in 69
Staaten ist Homosexualität sogar
verboten und strafbar etwa die Hälfte
davon liegt in Afrika Beispiel Uganda
dort werden Homosexuelle schon länger
verfolgt jetzt hat das Parlament die
Gesetze noch weiter verschärft und
ermöglicht damit auch die Todesstrafe
Susann von Lojewski berichtet
musste fliehen fliehen aus seiner Heimat
Uganda Chris und seine Mitbewohner sind
homosexuell Männer zu lieben aber ist in
Uganda strikt verboten sie wohnen in
einem Safe House am Stadtrand von
Nairobi in Kenia und warten seit Jahren
auf Asyl im Westen
sehr sehr gefährlich uganda ist ein
schreckliches Land für Schwule für
Transfrauen und für all diese Menschen
wenn jetzt Parlamentsabgeordnete sagen
wenn wir die erwischen werden wir sie
kastrieren einsperren oder mit dem Tode
bestrafen wirklich
in dieser Woche hat das sogar indische
Parlament das Gesetz gegen
lgbtq-menschen noch einmal verschärft
die Debatte darüber beispiellos homophob
wir werden die Vollzugsbeamten stärken
um klar zu machen dass für Homosexuelle
kein Platz in Uganda ist
das Gesetz sieht im schlimmsten Fall
sogar die Todesstrafe vor für
homosexuelle Handlungen auch
heterosexuellen die queere Menschen
nicht melden drohen hohe Haftstrafen bei
der Menschenrechtsorganisation endet die
international hoffen Sie das Ugandas
Präsident muss seveni das Gesetz nicht
unterschreibt
wenn er das Gesetz unterschreibt dann
hoffen wir dass die AktivistInnen in
Uganda mit Hilfe der regionalen und
internationalen Gemeinschaft vor Gericht
ziehen
schon einmal hat das Oberste Gericht
Ugandas ein weniger scharfes Gesetz
gekippt gegen homophobe Tendenzen und
Gewalt gegen die Community aber hat das
nicht geholfen
rund zweieinhalb Wochen nach dem
Amoklauf bei den Zeugen Jehovas in
Hamburg hat die Gemeinde an die Opfer
erinnert an der Trauerfeier nahmen gut
3000 Menschen teil darunter auch
Angehörige und Überlebende am 9 März
hatte einen ehemaliges Mitglied der
Zeugen Jehovas sieben Menschen getötet
danach erschoss sich der Mann selbst
und jetzt nach München Norbert dort
hatte seinen ersten Auftritt ja der hat
offenbar so richtig Bock auf Bayern eine
Ehre und Auszeichnung sei das für ihn
sagte der 49-Jährige die Mannschaft sei
super der Gewinn von Meisterschaft Pokal
und Champions League das Ziel zuvor aber
Abrechnung der bayern-spitze mit
Vorgänger nagelsmann
der Auftritt der Bayern-Bosse heute war
eine Aufführung in zwei Akten zunächst
ohne Thomas Tuchel der Blick zurück mit
der Begründung für die vorzeitige
Trennung von Julian nagelsmann das ist
jetzt auch keine Phase mehr ist sondern
einfach diese Konstellation nicht mehr
gepasst hat wir haben gesagt hat von
zehn Bundesligaspielen 5 verloren in der
Champions League allerdings hat
nagelsmann die Mannschaft bis ins
Viertelfinale geführt und damit kommt
Thomas Tuchel ins Spiel der weiß was von
ihm in München erwartet wird es geht um
uns gewinnen somit sind die die die
Verantwortung die Verpflichtung ist es
ist ist klar es kann keine
Missverständnisse geben Anlaufzeit
bekommt Tuchel nicht er übernimmt von
nagelsmann eine Mannschaft die in den
nächsten Wochen ihre Topleistung abrufen
soll man kann mit diesem Kater um um
jeden Titel spielen sind
konkurrenzfähig auf auf absolut höchsten
Niveau nicht weniger als das Triple ist
das Ziel für Thomas Tuchel und das wäre
sicher ganz nach dem Geschmack der
Bayern Bosse
ja und jetzt zum Fußball Highlight heute
abend Deutschland gegen Peru in 90
Minuten ist Anpfiff Jochen Breyer in
Mainz ist zwar nur ein
Freundschaftsspiel aber für das DFB-Team
da gibt's ja mehr
um sehr viel sogar Norbert es geht darum
Kredit zurückzugewinnen nach der
enttäuschenden Weltmeisterschaft der
neuer Sportdirektor Rudi Völler sagt das
wichtigste heute Abend ist die Fans zu
begeistern und wir haben mal nachgefragt
was die Fans heute erwarten
spielerische wollte ich nicht viel
die müssen sich erstmal darauf hin bist
du mehr Spaß wieder haben dass die Fans
wieder mitgehen können das wäre das
beste eigentlich wann die Mannschaft
Leistung zeigt und kämpft dann denke ich
dass die Zuschauer mitgehen
ja die Mannschaft ist übrigens gerade
hier angekommen in 15 Monaten steigt die
Europameisterschaft in Deutschland bis
dahin soll eine Euphorie rund um die
Nationalelf entstehen und heute soll mit
einem Mitreisenden Auftritt der Anfang
gemacht werden danke Jochen wir sehen
uns gleich wieder 20:15 Uhr ZDF
Sportstudio live Deutschland gegen Peru
schauen wir mal ne ne
morgen früh Pläne hat der sollte eines
einkalkulieren die Nacht wird kürzer
denn die Sommerzeit kommt und Punkt zwei
werden die Zeiger um eine Stunde
vorgestellt auf 3 Uhr damit soll Energie
gespart werden der Effekt ist jedoch
umstritten
das Wetter will noch nichts vom Sommer
wissen es wird noch mal kühler die
Details hat gleich Christa Orben das
heute journal mit Marietta Slomka in der
Halbzeitpause gegen halb zehn machen sie
sich noch einen schönen Abend und bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend heute Nacht werden die
Uhren auf Sommerzeit umgestellt das
Wetter wird aber eher spät winterlich
was passiert dieses Tief mit dem
Schauerwetter zieht jetzt nach Osten ab
und dahinter macht sich Polar Luft auf
den Weg die wird erst noch einmal
gebremst weil ein neues Tief morgen dann
in der Mitte und im Süden Regen bringt
aber in der Nacht auf Montag ist der Weg
frei für ein Kaltlufteinbruch aus Norden
und Regen geht in Schnee über das ist
aber auch völlig in Ordnung so früh im
Jahr soll die Natur ruhig noch ein
bisschen wechsaft das Wetter abbekommen
heute Nacht ziehen sich die Schauer also
in Richtung Osten zurück aus Südwesten
beruhigt sich der Wind morgens gibt's
dann westlich des Rheins aber die neuen
Regenwolken die Temperaturen sinken auf
acht bis drei Grad morgen steigen Sie
auf 7 bis 14 Grad und das Regenwald aus
dem Südwesten breitet sich weiter aus
sodass es dann nachmittags zwischen
Nordrhein-Westfalen Rheinland-Pfalz und
Südbrandenburg und aus Sachsen länger
regnen kann südlich davon gibt es
Schauerwetter mit einzelnen Gewittern
Auflockerungen aber auch einzelnen
stürmischen böhnen nördlich davon bleibt
es trocken und ruhig an den Küsten mit
viel sonnen und es gibt schon Nordwind
und der wird dann kräftiger bringt uns
am Montag und am Dienstag die Polarluft
mit Schneeschauer und Nachtfrösten aber
schon am Mittwoch wird es schnell wieder
milder der März bleibt einfach
unbeständig tschüss